what's been really interesting for me in
my 15 years of practicing the martial
arts and and my 15 years of being rabbi
is the incredible number of similarities
I guess if you want to look at some of
the core similarities one would be the
obvious discipline and commitment you
know in religious language we sometimes
talk about devotion but you can be
devoted to other things as well so for
me I've been devoted to the martial arts
in karate specifically for pretty much
the same amount of time that I've been
ordained i would say that repetition is
incredibly important in both whether
it's organized religion and ritual or it
is in training martial arts training I
would say a more abstract idea that I
think is probably the most important is
the idea of openness the idea that
paradoxically the more open you become
which can sometimes make us feel
uncomfortable the more powerful you
become and it's something that takes a
long time to master in the martial arts
but I think as we go along in the human
journey it it has great application as
well and I know from personal experience
as well as from preaching on the pulpit
that sometimes when you become most
vulnerable you paradoxically also reach
your fullest potential and one level i'm
talking about humility a kind of
openness meaning you are you become an
empty vessel and and realized that there
is a tremendous amount that you have to
learn so you know it takes a while
before you get your black belt and so
humility is just a kind of openness to
or receptivity to the wisdom of your
instructors of your teachers but also
there are certain techniques in the
martial arts that i can't really
demonstrate on a website where openness
plays a key role in essence where you
almost use your adversaries strength
against him or her aikido and jujitsu
probably are two of the martial arts
that follow that principle the best
well I think you know a lot of us think
we know what what a warrior is a fighter
a soldier someone who engages in combat
but a spiritual warrior and i just spoke
recently at a military installation
about about my book and about how
spirituality can actually be very much
tied up in the notion of being a warrior
a spiritual warrior is someone who is
able to do battle not just with forces
outside of him or herself but also with
those things within us that can hold us
back from achieving our greatest
capacities and and potentials so whether
it means fighting our inner demons
whether it means grappling with those
forces that are holding us back from
from evolving or whether it is dealing
with something in life that that we
really are having a hard time getting
through that's where I think the spirit
comes into play and that's where I think
we can become spiritual warriors and I
think also when we develop some of those
capacities of being a spiritual warrior
it allows us to deal with the sad but
inevitable challenges that that every
human being has to face in life almost
every person whether whether it be the
loss of a parent going through a breakup
or a divorce losing a job there are many
and varied obstacles that we all have to
face in life and I think a spiritual
warrior gets more arrows for the quiver
so to speak in order to better handle
those challenges
you